yeah I think it's age you know an
experience and yeah it is it's a really
interesting complex complicated industry
to navigate and it definitely took me a
few years to figure out my place and all
that yeah and the hand that feeds them
is always willing to bite them so they
should write back don't sign a major
record label deal and kids yeah I mean
it's it's as I said you know it's really
complex and really complicated you know
and some people have really great
experiences and other people don't but
you know these contracts are really like
long-term commitments and you know if
people come and go from record labels or
from you know management companies or
whatever but you all sort of still stuck
in in that contract so it's you know if
it if things don't sort of fall into
place it can be really like lonely and
isolating and yeah and I'm not very
enjoyable I've had to be know some
really enjoyable moments but I've had
some pretty tough ones as well yeah and
I've asked for more money and I wouldn't
have spent and like so much money on
lawyers have done absolutely nothing
anyway
yeah well actually I wasn't really right
in the beginning I was just sort of
looking to get noticed you know and so
have my you know my music out there and
it does it overnight it just became very
mainstream and very and very successful
and it wasn't you know if I had known
what was going to happen then I would
definitely not have signed that small
deal because it would have made
absolutely no sense but you know I that
wasn't where I saw things going I
thought I was going to be a sort of like
indie act that you know I thought I'd
support Jamie T or be part of the Thames
beat scene which was what was happening
at the time and and things like you know
just grew and grew and got really and
got really really crazy and then it
became about maintaining that not just
for me but for everybody else you know
everyone wanted to be involved with the
thing that was working and bringing
loads of cash in and so when things
sights sort of might not really go to
Tran with my third album I felt just
like a you know a massive failure really
and I'd not just like for myself but I
let everybody else around me down and
that was that was a real struggle so
this album has really been about sort of
figuring out what it is that my
intentions are with this work and you
know it wasn't really to get on the
radio and it wasn't really about
branding endorsements it was about
explaining how I felt and putting that
to music and I feel like I've achieved
that and that's why it's just such a
lovely thing to be nominated for this
award because that's obviously crossed
over in some way now I mean actually I
would really like Nadine Chartres to win
because I think that you know there is a
bit bit of a sort of like cultural war
going on at the moment and
it feels like there is so you know art
and culture is the one sort of enemy of
capitalism and globe you know globalism
and it's interesting to me that politics
can be in such a state and they're not
really be a sort of resistance in terms
of culture and art and so the Nadine's
album is is exactly that and and should
be being played everywhere and all over
the road year because it's that's that's
what musics for I think you know where's
the clash where are the Sex Pistols of
today they're not here for some reason
yeah it would it would make a huge
difference to me because it would you
know I do feel a little bit like there
is a caricature version of myself which
is portrayed in the mainstream press and
the artists part of me gets lost a lot
of the time and so yeah so - I mean
already being nominated has helped with
that immensely but the win would just be
amazing yeah